Transcription: Almudena Torrecilla
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir.
Qui dans cette salle
a vraiment envie de réussir ?
Quelle ambition ! J’adore !
(Rit.)
Et qui a déjà pris le temps,
mais vraiment le temps,
de définir sa propre réussite ?
Un peu moins, bon.
Mais en même temps, c’est normal.
De quoi parle-t-on
quand on parle de réussite ?
Est-ce qu’on parle de réussite
personnelle, professionnelle, familiale ?
Certains vont dire que la réussite,
c’est avoir de l’argent, du pouvoir,
la liberté.
J’étais un peu comme vous.
Je n’avais jamais réfléchi à ma réussite,
mais j’avais une certaine
idée de la réussite.
Je vais raconter une histoire.
Vous allez voir.
Il y aura deux salles, deux ambiances.
Ce qu'on voit et ce qu'on ressent.
La vitrine et l’arrière-boutique.
Nos parents nous disent que pour réussir,
il faut faire de grandes études.
Je suis fille d’immigrés
et pour mes parents,
pour qu’on réussisse et qu’on prenne
notre place dans cette société,
il fallait qu’on fasse
les meilleures écoles.
Heureusement, j’étais
bonne élève, ça aide.
J’ai donc fait une prépa
et j’ai intégré une des trois meilleures
écoles de commerce de France.
Donc la réussite scolaire,
elle est cochée.
Puis la société nous dit que,
pour réussir, il faut suivre ses passions.
Depuis toute petite,
j’ai très vite compris que le monde
ne s’arrêtait pas à Paris.
Mes parents nous amenaient souvent
en vacances au Sénégal
et je voyageais énormément
dans les livres.
Je rêvais d’aventure,
d’exploration et de découverte
et j’ai été servie.
Un lama m’a poursuivie
en plein Machu Picchu.
Je me suis perdue
dans la jungle cambodgienne
et, à mes 28 ans, j’ai posé mes pieds
dans mon quarantième pays du monde.
Donc, si réussir,
c’est suivre ses passions,
ça aussi, c’est coché.
Puis, l’école nous dit :
« Non, la réussite,
c’est trouver un poste à responsabilités
dans un grand groupe. »
Après mon diplôme,
j’ai intégré un groupe média
pour lequel j’explorais
et je lançais de nouveaux marchés.
Pendant plus de six ans, j'ai travaillé
dans plus de dix pays africains.
J’ai managé des équipes multiculturelles,
car juste pour info, l’Afrique, c’est
54 pays et 54 cultures différentes.
Je gérais des projets estimés
à des millions de dollars.
Je voyageais en business class
et je vivais dans des hôtels cinq étoiles.
Donc la réussite professionnelle,
elle aussi, elle est cochée.
On pourrait s’arrêter là.
J’ai 29 ans, ma famille
et mes amis sont très fiers.
Je coche les cases de la réussite en soi.
Mais qu’en est-il
de la réussite pour moi ?
Est-ce que le visage qu’on montre au monde
est le même qu’on retrouve
chez nous le soir ?
Je ne sais pas pour vous,
mais pour moi, ce n’était pas le cas.
Plus je montais
dans la hiérarchie de l’entreprise,
plus je m’éloignais de moi-même.
Je passais ma vie
dans les avions et les hôtels,
loin de ma famille et de mes amis,
pour défendre des projets
qui avaient du sens en soi,
mais qui n’en avaient plus pour moi.
Alors que dans mes précédents voyages,
j’avais une réelle ouverture d’esprit,
là, je ne voyageais plus, je me déplaçais,
étriquée dans un entre-soi
qui m’étouffait.
Le plus dur dans cette histoire,
c’est la culpabilité que l’on ressent.
Car plus j’exprimais mon mal-être,
plus on m’envoyait cette image
d’une femme forte, persévérante,
solaire, parfois capricieuse,
mais qui arriverait à tout gérer.
Sauf qu’à un moment donné,
je ne gérais plus.
Mais je m’étais convaincue
qu’il fallait que je garde la face.
Donc il me paraissait normal de porter
une écharpe et des manches longues en été
pour cacher l’eczéma
qui s’était propagé sur tout mon corps,
ou encore de courir dans ma chambre
d’hôtel après avoir signé un beau contrat
parce que je faisais une crise d’angoisse.
Deux salles, deux ambiances,
une girl qui réussit aux yeux du monde
et une autre qui pleure dans sa chambre.
Cette situation dure pendant plus d’un an,
jusqu’au jour où mon corps m’a lâchée
et l’arrêt total s’est imposé.
C’était un burn-out.
J’ai passé des moments
sombres et difficiles.
J’ai été suivie par des spécialistes,
mais des questions
se bousculaient dans ma tête.
En réalité,
pourquoi moi ?
J’avais tout bien fait.
Et puis, est-ce que j’étais
la seule à le vivre ?
Mais la question qui me taraudait
vraiment, c’était :
« Mais en réalité,
je cours derrière quoi ?
Est-ce ça, une vie réussie ? »
Pour mieux comprendre ma situation,
j’ai décidé d’investiguer.
J’ai échangé avec 200 salariés
âgés de 27 à 40 ans,
qui, comme moi, naviguaient
entre ces deux salles, deux ambiances.
Et j’ai eu trois grandes découvertes.
La première,
c’est que tout le monde me dit qu’il veut
un travail en accord avec ses valeurs,
et quand je demande
quelles sont ces valeurs,
ils sont incapables de me répondre.
Ils n’ont jamais pris le temps,
que ce soit dans la sphère scolaire,
professionnelle ou privée, de réfléchir
aux valeurs qui les animaient.
Deuxièmement, ils me disent qu'ils ont
envie de conjuguer réussite personnelle
et collective,
mais avouent avoir du mal
à décrypter leur environnement.
Quand on y pense, est-ce qu’on n’est pas
tous dans les mêmes environnements,
avec les mêmes grilles de lecture
et les mêmes types de profils ?
Est-ce qu’on n’aurait pas du mal
à se connecter à des personnes
qui ne nous ressemblent pas ?
Je vous laisse y réfléchir.
Et troisièmement, ils me disent
qu’ils veulent tous changer le monde,
mais ils ont plein d'appréhension.
On me parle du syndrome de l’imposteur,
de celui du bon ou de la bonne élève,
de la peur de l’échec,
puis j’en passe.
Pour être honnête, cette situation
m’a beaucoup soulagée
car je me suis dit qu’au moins les
questions existentielles qui m’habitaient
étaient partagées par beaucoup de monde.
Mais après ça, qu’est-ce que j’en fais ?
Je me retrouve là dans la même galère.
Ce qui m’a beaucoup aidée, c’est de me
mettre dans une posture d’exploration.
Vous l’aurez compris,
je suis très curieuse.
J’aime questionner, découvrir, rencontrer.
C’est donc naturellement
que je me suis dit :
« Pourquoi je n’irais pas voir des
personnes qui semblent avoir réussi ? -
maintenant, je fais attention -
pour qu’elles me partagent
leur propre définition de la réussite ? »
Je voulais sortir des carcans de la
réussite classique, la fameuse vitrine.
Je voulais comprendre quelle est la vision
de la réussite pour une personne
qui a réalisé son rêve
d’être champion du monde.
Quelle est la vision de la réussite
pour une personne qui a fui
la guerre dans son pays,
qui aujourd’hui utilise
son art comme défouloir ?
Quelle est la vision de la réussite
pour une personne
issue d’une famille bourgeoise parisienne
et pour qui le destin est quasi tracé ?
Ça, ça m'intéressait.
J’ai échangé avec plus de 70 artistes,
sportifs, entrepreneurs, salariés,
un rappeur, un amiral
de la Marine nationale,
en passant par une personne qui a créé
son propre métier de chocologue,
qui m’ont partagé leur propre cheminement
et leur définition de la réussite.
La principale leçon que j’ai retenue,
c’est que ces personnes ont su définir
ce qui était important pour elles.
Elles ont une vision,
une ambition, une direction,
quand bien même elles n’en
maîtrisent pas l’itinéraire exact.
Cette découverte m’a replongée
dans mes souvenirs de voyage.
Dans la tradition rwandaise,
en Afrique de l’Est,
les femmes fabriquent un panier
qu’elles peuvent charger sur leur tête
pour transporter de quelconques trésors à
l’intention des personnes qu’elles aiment.
Le couvercle qui protège ces trésors
s’appelle le « gatemeri ».
Pour moi, ce couvercle s'apparente à un
supplément d'âme propre à chaque individu
qui couvre et protège
notre patrimoine personnel,
ce qui est important pour nous,
telle une boussole intérieure
qui nous guide vers le chemin
de notre propre réussite.
Cette démarche a été
tellement salutaire pour moi
que j’ai décidé de partager les récits
de celles et ceux qui m’ont inspirée
et qui m’inspirent à définir ma réussite
dans un podcast.
D’un point de vue professionnel,
ce podcast m’a permis
de trouver mon « sweet spot ».
Le « sweet spot », c’est un terme
qu’on utilise beaucoup dans le sport,
notamment dans le tennis ou au golf.
Transposé dans le domaine du travail,
c’est le croisement entre ce
qu’on aime faire et ce qu’on sait faire.
Et mon « sweet spot » à moi,
c’est de connecter et de créer du lien.
Aujourd’hui, je le fais
à travers le podcast
où je connecte des personnes inspirantes
avec des milliers d’auditeurs
et aussi à travers des ateliers
et des expériences pluridisciplinaires
pour insuffler cet esprit d’ouverture
et d’exploration dans les entreprises.
Et demain ?
Je ne sais pas.
D'après le World Economic Forum, on fera
au moins neuf métiers dans notre vie.
Donc, au lieu de me prendre la tête
à chercher un job passion,
je préfère développer mes compétences
autour de mon « sweet spot »
pour naviguer sereinement dans ce monde
du travail en pleine mutation.
Mais la réussite, elle n’est pas
que professionnelle,
elle est aussi personnelle.
Le plus dur dans cette aventure,
c’est de faire face à son propre miroir.
Aujourd’hui, je prends beaucoup
de temps pour moi
et j’ai de la chance d’avoir
autour de moi ma tribu,
que j’appelle « mes gars sûrs »,
composée de ma famille, de mes amis,
de ma thérapeute, de mes mentors,
qui m’aident à repérer et à accepter
mes déséquilibres personnels
quels qu’ils soient.
Car du haut de mes presque 32 ans,
je ne suis pas là pour vous faire
une leçon sur la réussite.
Je suis moi-même en cheminement.
Je tâtonne, je me trompe, je doute.
Mais ce dont je suis sûre aujourd’hui,
c’est que je ne peux plus
me mentir à moi-même.
Donc j’ai envie de vous inviter
à faire un pas de côté
pour réfléchir à votre propre réussite.
Pas celle de vos parents, pas celle
de la société, pas celle de votre école,
mais celle qui vient de vos propres choix,
de vos propres aspirations,
de votre propre ambition.
Car cette introspection,
cette richesse intérieure,
c’est ce qui fera votre force
dans le monde extérieur.
Je veux vous partager
une définition de la réussite
de quelqu’un que j’admire énormément
mais que je n’ai pas eu la chance
d’avoir sur le podcast.
C’est celle de l’écrivaine Maya Angelou,
qui dit que la réussite,
c’est de vous aimer vous-même,
d’aimer ce que vous faites
et comment vous le faites.
Et pour vous mettre en mouvement vers
la définition de votre propre réussite,
je vais vous partager un exercice
que je propose dans mes ateliers.
Je vais vous demander
d’imaginer là maintenant
que vous avez 75 ans,
vous êtes en pleine forme.
Vous organisez une fête
pour votre anniversaire,
vous rassemblez toutes
les personnes que vous aimez
et une personne parmi vos invités
va faire un discours sur vous,
une personne qui vous est très chère.
Qu’aimeriez-vous qu’elle dise ?
Je vous mets au défi cette semaine
de prendre le temps,
vraiment le temps,
et de vous munir d’un papier
et d’un stylo et d’écrire ce discours.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)